[Music]
if Carolina's insider and today I am
gonna be a zombie
hey guys for our VFX studio in LA with
Sydney from beat I'm excited I had never
been in prosthetics before I want seeing
the process and I really
see how it'll look and feel on my face
it's gonna feel like it's meant to be
there
[Music]
all right getting my zombie mordrem on
yeah this is the newest fall fashions
within these days they left this outfit
really compliments my personalities
inside
I like the swamp look to begin with
we're gonna clean her skin as we clean
our skin we're pretty much going to ball
capper so we're gonna pull her hair back
this ball cap does not need to be
beautiful because there's gonna be a big
weight over it as well I feel like a
warm or like a newborn baby
[Music]
it's like you're gonna cut off my ear
you did it yeah my ear made it told
transformation are you ready
well she's ready let's do it I'm ready
to get some of that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
doesn't feel as uncomfortable as I
thought it would it surprisingly feels
so comfortable like an event obviously
sitting for makeup definitely makes me
more cautious of what I'm doing somebody
else because I've had stuff going to be
aware of it
this is the worst holding the prosthetic
pulling hairs out we're moving is a big
one I'm always asking questions how am i
doing like might we be too rough on you
while we move your head too much so you
know that's sort of one thing that's
good about being in the chair as well as
doing makeup
[Music]
that's us getting a facial it's like
weird that I'm comparing this to a
facial in a field like that
it's a dancer so long for Beth the
zombie just throw anything down that's
why you know I'm going with that
undertone of purple we're gonna make it
look all bruising and nasty and this is
just the other time so how weird does
this look right now right it's all
purple doesn't make any sense once I put
a top coat on this you're gonna be like
there it is so this is going to be her
flesh tone basically and this is a
technique called dry brushing and so
basically what I'm doing you'll see the
zombies start to pop right you'll see
the color start to just go
now it's like it's almost there and you
just done two colors on them that's it
I'm gonna do like little small dots
because when you look at the skin you
see all these different colors right and
this just helps to start out the flush
[Music]
the oghuz there's some spots
[Music]
I like to do a little bit of usiness
changing the color that took a little
bit
[Music]
it's better now
[Music]
[Applause]
that's like being at the nail salon this
zombie world
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm just gonna spray a lot of this also
it gives it a little bit of Sheen this
is just a sealer I'm gonna dry off a
little bit of shine add you know more of
like a fleshy look to it so it's time
for Beth to get a hairdo her makeup done
got her nails done beautiful gorgeous
yeah it's looking like a good hair day
for that as I'm flying beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
do I look glam this is all not skin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
coming back to life
so right now just use a little bit
dynamics and alcohol to try to lift it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my deep
[Applause]
[Music]
what's that got to say nothing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]